hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the monday morning podcast for
monday
august 10th 2020 what's going on
how are you oh jesus
get in the pool man
jump in the water somewhere this
summer's almost gone how the [ __ ] is it
already august 10th
so [ __ ] crazy we've all been on
summer vacation other than stressing out
since like march i can't believe this
[ __ ] year is flying by
it is flying by and ladies and gentlemen
uh
professional sports are back with a
vengeance
this is the first day that i can
remember it's sunday by the way sunday
afternoon
um my lovely daughter's taking a nap
right now
my uh wonderful son i signed him on the
uh wheel of fortune cause you always
have to describe
your family members or your wife with
adjectives they like that well you got
to be like
uh who's here with you i got my uh
smoking hot wife
uh gabriella i got uh
my uh drinking buddy sammy out there i
got
man titted freddy you know you got to do
that so i'm gonna i'm gonna go wheel of
fortune here
my beautiful daughter is sleeping and my
wonderful son is also sleeping so i can
sneak out here
and uh and and knock out a podcast here
for y'all um
anyway jesus christ we're only halfway
through the day it is 12 39 pacific
coast time here on a sunday
and there's all kinds of hockey left to
be played
how about oh i don't want to say it i
don't want to jinx them but i got to say
how about the [ __ ] toronto maple
leafs
they blow a three nothing [ __ ]
lead i watch that game i watch them
slowly
just just do what they do to their
[ __ ] fans all the time
uh what do you think we're gonna win
this game now it's time to take out the
[ __ ]
take out the [ __ ] iron maiden slowly
close it on our goddamn fan base
whatever the hell it is they did and i
just sat there
absolutely disgusted
watching them blow that [ __ ] lead and
then the very next game right i've
turned it on a little bit late
uh old tortorelli's got the [ __ ]
columbus blue jackets he's doing a hell
of a job over there
i'm loving the new sometimes happy
uh uh uh tortorelli is that how you say
his [ __ ] name i like that guy he's an
angry [ __ ] lunatic i relate and he's
trying not to be
um it reminds me dick vermeel when he
had the eagles in 1980 against uh the
raiders he he over prepared him
he burned him out before the super bowl
but the man learned
and he came back in 1999 after leaving
nfl
coaching for a while the man came back
he cried after every game he made it
okay as a man to get a little choked up
and he he he had his he didn't have the
foot all the way down the whole year and
god damn it they won they won on the
last play against the tennessee titans
and uh and the late great steve mcnair
so i think that that's uh just make sure
i'm saying his name right here
columbus tortorella sorry
sorry my my apologies as a german
irishman apology to all
italian americans tortorella i'm loving
what he's doing out there
okay so tortorella's got his team comes
in
then they go up columbus blue jackets go
up three to nothing
the very next game and i was just like
it was five minutes left and old
freckles oh freckles stay there to the
end what does he do
he shuts off the [ __ ] tv disgusted
goes downstairs you know happy for
columbus
but disgusted that you know i just you
know i like
i like the maple leafs right so i go
downstairs
i have dinner okay i eat fast
i come back 10 15 [ __ ] minutes later
whatever the hell it was 20 minutes
later
still have the nhl channel on and i'm
sitting there
i watched for three minutes before i
realized this wasn't the the wrap-up of
the game
and say what do they need to do as my
buddy says uh toronto's too top heavy
they got they though they have all these
goal scorers they lose a lot of games
six to five they don't have any money to
get a [ __ ] defenseman
he's also saying the bruins aren't going
to be able to afford tory krug and i
said is he going to end up in toronto
and he said they can't afford him i
don't know
so i'm sitting there thinking that this
is going to be the end and there's going
to be another [ __ ] head coach
in toronto selling his [ __ ] house or
putting his condo up on
on the market whatever the hell it is
and
they're talking intermission i was
sitting there for three four minutes and
then i finally looked down and it was
three to three
and i was like what the [ __ ] just
happened what the [ __ ]
just happened well evidently they pulled
the goalie
and scored three goals three unanswered
goals
they scored and i gotta think
that the great patrick wah was sitting
somewhere
going was i did i [ __ ] call it did i
call it
you should have taken him out with nine
minutes left you would have won [ __ ]
six to three
um anyway so my beloved boston bruins
uh lost again today we went owen three
we lost to the number one seed look out
there in philly
we lost to the number one seeded flyers
they want the number one seed when we
lost to them they were just the [ __ ]
flyers now they're the number one seed
in the east we lost to them
then we lost to tampa and now we lost to
um who the [ __ ] did we lose to we lost
to uh
washington the capitals who just they
just [ __ ] own us
they i can't remember the last time we
beat that team i love that dude [ __ ]
wilson by the way a lot of people think
he's dirty i don't think he's dirty i
think he's a complete player
all right i think he's a complete player
and the people that criticize him are a
little too sensitive
all right i love milan lou cheech i love
them with the bruins and i but am i
going to sit there and act like he
didn't stab a few guys in the balls with
the stick
the man did it okay
was he a dirty player no is he a clean
player he's well-rounded
this is what you have to understand if
you take your stick and you [ __ ] stab
somebody in the [ __ ] taint with it
as much as people are gonna say you
shouldn't do that [ __ ] people out there
like you know this [ __ ] stabs
people in the tank that's gonna give you
some space on the ice
it's gonna give your top players space
on the ice and this is what that man is
supposed to be doing
i'm loving lou cheech having a having a
fun time he looks like he's having the
best time ever out there in calgary
calgary one
the hated habs the blue blanca douche
um canadians look out for them
a 12 seed
[ __ ] beat the pittsburgh penguins the
dirty birds out there in [ __ ] western
pennsylvania
hey we can cross check you into the
boards but don't do it to us but if you
do it we're in our uniform we'll put you
in the ring of
honor pittsburgh penguins lose
to the montreal canadiens and and
speaking of patrick wah
we have to talk about the curse of lord
patrick
okay when those silly socks
wearing pocket square heaven
racist french fans [ __ ]
booed that guy out of that the greatest
goaltender since [ __ ] kendrick they
booed that guy
out of the [ __ ] city he goes to
colorado colorado wasn't a [ __ ]
hockey city denver colorado
they like the broncos ipa and growing
weed
that's what they did out there you know
and listening to john denver
rocky mountain colorado
do you think now is john denver was he
from
colorado or did he just write that last
song because his stage name was denver
or was it his real name we got to look
up we got to look up
we gotta look up john denver okay if i'm
gonna say tortorella
correctly john denver
um all right no he was henry john
duchendorff oh yeah he had to change
that
keep it going for henry duchendorff
um known professionally as john denver
was an american singer songwriter
let's see where where where oh where did
he [ __ ] go he was from roswell new
mexico well being from the east coast
that's close enough okay he jumps on
what is
that the 25 is that what it is you take
it north
35 i know runs through right through
[ __ ] waco texas all the way up to
minnesota if i remember correctly
from my road dog and dash uh-huh
um
oh he was from ross grew up in roswell
new mexico all right
okay change it to denver and then wrote
rocky mountain high colorado i mean this
that's
right there is called building your
brand
rest in peace john denver way to go all
right now what else what other surprises
were there in the nhl
the chicago blackhawks winners of three
stanley cup championships over the last
decade
everyone thought they got a little too
old what the [ __ ] happened
and what happens they came out and they
beat
one of my favorite teams in the west the
loaded
edmonton oilers i was really looking
forward to watching them
throughout the playoffs they were sort
of my team in the west i still love the
blackhawks i love chicago
i i you know i gotta be honest with you
i'm really a [ __ ]
you know an equal opportunity fan here
i'm enjoying [ __ ] uh
phil kessel down in [ __ ] arizona
i'd like to see them do something i
don't give a
[ __ ] all right this is my only thing i
don't even hate the flyers i mean
i don't know philly fans i'm kind of on
the fence with
you know i respect their passion but i
feel like they've become a parody of
themselves
with the bad behavior which reminded me
of like bobby knight the great bobby
knight towards the end of his career i
felt like he was throwing chairs because
he
people were like i came here to see you
throw a chair
you know when i feel like philly fans
they're like all right
nobody's done anything in a while all
right i'll stick my fingers down my
throat and puke on a kid
kept it going espn's talking about us
again i got the santa claus story going
again
i just don't know if i buy it anymore
i'm not saying that they're not lunatics
they're not animals that they won't do
that [ __ ]
i'm kind of questioning the motivation
now
i feel like uh their fan behavior was
where like hair metal ended up in the
early 90s
where it's like well what do we do now
i've i've mimed
in this video i've mimed uh licking a
[ __ ]
i've licked my guitar i've pelvic pumps
i i'm wearing more makeup than [ __ ]
nine drag queens where do i go from here
i
i really feel like philly fans have
painted themselves into a corner
where they're gonna have to uh they're
gonna have to start attacking each other
having said that it is exciting to see
the flyers
be the number one seed and actually
think what if the flyers won the cup
how [ __ ] crazy that city would go
that that would be awesome to see
um that's it the only team i really root
against is just the canadians just
because like i'm supposed to but even
them
they've been like such a non-factor for
so goddamn long
with the curse of patrick wah 27
years strong um
they got to get that monkey off their
back so we should see what happens and
the reason why i like to root for
toronto's because i know
canadian fans hate the maple leaf still
i don't know why
but they used to be like the celtics and
lakers going back and forth with uh
winning championships
stanley cups and as mentioned before the
the toronto maple leafs have not won
since uh joe namath was playing for the
jets they've won since 1967.
so the amazing thing is i is that i they
are still
the closest team to the montreal
canadiens as far as like stanley cup
victories uh let's look that up most
come on come on you could do it most
stanley
cup victories victory victor
victories all right the canadians have
24.
um you know they count those ones where
they beat the [ __ ]
the uh i don't know the montreal maroons
but why not why the [ __ ] not right the
celtics count all of theirs so i can't
can't [ __ ] too much about that
god bless them god bless them in their
24 [ __ ]
stanley cups uh yes the maple leafs
stopped at lucky 13. so
if they were to win one they would be
number they'd still be number two
fourteen they'd be they'd only be ten
behind
which you know back in a six
team league well i don't even think was
still in striking distance
it's uh you know no one's ever gonna
catch them
not in my lifetime there's no [ __ ]
way i mean if montreal keeps doing what
they do and then you gotta
you gotta have toronto is somehow gonna
win [ __ ] 11
cups and i'm 52 years old i i
in a 30-team league uh
i think i'm going to accept that i'm
going to accept the fact that i'm going
to be on my deathbed and the montreal
canadiens will still have
the most but you never know you never
know i always have to think positive
all right who's number three oh you know
who it is it's a detroit red wings
with 11. and then surprisingly
at number four there's a two-way tie
with the boston bruins and the chicago
blackhawks
edmonton's got five pittsburgh has five
the islanders
won four in a row early they peaked
quarterback of the team banging the head
cheerleader
graduated didn't go to college got fat
kept wearing your [ __ ] varsity jacket
you can't button it anymore
what is going on with the islanders new
york rangers have four
new jersey devils have three there's a
lot of big names here
i mean look at this [ __ ] the montreal
canadies the maple leafs and the red
wings
have won 30 set 48
they've almost won half has it been 100
stanley cups at this point i don't
[ __ ] know
there's a bunch of people with two and
all of that [ __ ] um expand the statistic
um well i guess having six stanley cups
is a pretty big deal
um it's kind of funny though when you
look at this one two three
four five
wait a minute one two three four five
[ __ ] rangers blow it i was gonna top
the top
five um
teams with the most stanley cups are all
original six teams
and um you have to respect the red wings
the maple leafs and the canadians
but the bruins and the blackhawks with
only six
and then the rangers i mean jesus christ
the rangers with [ __ ]
four um he only had to beat five other
teams and all they could get was [ __ ]
four granted the canadians and maple
leafs would take most of them but still
um i do think it's incredible that uh
let me just my question for you at what
point does it become a curse
okay because the [ __ ]
new york rangers i remember my whole
life growing up they were chanting 1940
throughout the 80s
and they were they only that was only
you know
40 something years and then they ended
the curse in 94 so that was
54 years it took them to win a cup and
they were like the curse is over i can
die now
the [ __ ] maple leafs are not
considered cursed for whatever reason
and they have a healthy 53 years i mean
next year they got to win it next year
or else their drought is longer than the
[ __ ] rangers
see this is the deal as much of a [ __ ]
as a montreal canadian fan can be
they they still they're too nice up
there at least to white people
and they don't chant the year
that's an east coast thing i think that
started with islander fans
probably because that they won four in a
row and i bet ranger fans probably [ __ ]
on them that new york rangers were the
only [ __ ] game in town
and then all of a sudden they came out
of nowhere and they won four [ __ ] in
a row
caught up to the [ __ ] uh and passed
the rangers
isn't that something the rangers only
won three when there was six teams
[ __ ] doormats but they also had a
problem too because no one respected the
game here
um i said here like i still live in new
york the game in new york
and i know that they had uh
or at least in the united states it
wasn't respected and that the rangers
had
issues with the [ __ ] circus would
come to town i remember reading this
it come to msg during the [ __ ]
playoffs so they would have to a lot of
times go play
in like maple leaf gardens or something
they'd have to play a home game
on the road so um
yeah so i can't i can't jump on them
listen i'm not here to [ __ ] on [ __ ]
people all right i'm here to be excited
that there's uh
that there's there's playoff hockey
coming and i'm already used to not
having crowds there
all right i don't need people banging on
the glass every time it goes into the
[ __ ] corner i've never understood
people doing that [ __ ]
um you know when you go to the zoo is
that what you do you're [ __ ] banging
the thing to get the lion going i mean
you know you know the thing could
[ __ ] kill you
have a little respect for the people
playing on the ice right
i'll tell you in a perfect world that
would just be a [ __ ] screen
like on somebody's back door and when
you did it luchith would go in there and
he'd [ __ ]
give you a little [ __ ] wake-up call
by the way lucicz
had a fight the other night uh i'm still
always gonna love that guy he was
fighting some guy in winnipeg that's who
calgary beat
and uh another one of my favorite teams
i love winnipeg and um
you know the other guy was giving away
like 20 25 pounds
to lucich and he was beyond the
gentleman
you know he ragdolled him a little bit
gave him a couple of [ __ ] hits and
when the one the guy went down to the
ice he didn't do anything and i believe
when i heard when the guy got up he said
thank you to him
it's a class act you know
um it's a classy [ __ ] move it's the
kind of thing that gets kicked you
kicked out of the ring of honor
in in the pittsburgh penguins franchise
sorry um whatever let's i'm just trying
to stir it up here trying to get excited
about quarantine stanley cup playoffs
in [ __ ] august we got a round robin
all right uh did anybody watch the moto
gp have i converted you to motorcycle
racing
um congratulations to brad
binder i hope i said his name it's not
binder is it brad binder brad binder i
don't know
and ktm um getting the big wing
in winning the uh czech republic uh
franco morbidelli
came in second johan zarco joe hanzark
however the [ __ ] you say it came in
third
was a great race i did think it was
funny it was just like a new star is
born with brad
binder it's like easy easy mark marquez
isn't out there
all right mark marquez isn't out this is
like when jordan was playing baseball
let's [ __ ] relax here
fabio cuatro unfortunately his yamaha
had uh
grip problems all weekend on the uh with
the rear wheel
so that just sucked you know what i mean
you didn't get to see the guy playing at
his uh playing riding in his top
[ __ ] level so um but it was a great
race nonetheless
definitely missing uh mark marquez
coming out
you know being out there on the track i
mean
let me see here when's he gonna be mark
marquez
schedule return what do we got here
when's he coming back
mark is recovering from successful
surgery and remain in the hospital for
up to 48 hours already saw that
mark is cleared to return from the
fracture july 23rd we already know what
happened
there despite his injury clearance mark
won't
race injured mark evaluating
five days ago mark marquez out of czech
republic so he sort of raced to race
after a heroic return just four days
after surgery
mark marquez will miss the how do you
be rno i mean that's some east european
thing
no vowel burnout race with uh
stefan brady brattle joining the team
i'm gonna stop butchering people's names
all right so i guess he's raced to race
here
so that's a big deal fabio cuatro in
that
that that rear tire um [ __ ] him over
on this race
could come back could oh oh that's how
good
mark marquez is he could actually come
back and at least make it exciting
towards the end uh and i'm betting you
know
provided the yamaha team figures out
what the [ __ ] was wrong with his bike
and he continues to be able to ride
something that's up to his level of
talent
all right and with that i got to tell
you man um i've been playing [ __ ]
drums and [ __ ]
and uh this new thing where i i [ __ ]
stretch for like 15 20 minutes before i
play
i totally [ __ ] relax i have my little
warm-ups that i do i sit down i have fun
and then i try to do that
that 16th note triplet thing that i've
been trying to figure out has changed my
[ __ ] life
as far as my practice i should say and
um just knowing
just going in and just not having like
yesterday i played it at this now i need
to play it at least at that
if not faster just letting go of all of
that and just being like yeah how do i
feel today
and it's not really feeling it right now
i just play a couple of songs and i come
back to it
and really just starting slow and
working my way up something i have heard
for [ __ ] 20 goddamn years something
dave elich has been telling me forever
i'm
finally applying it you know
and and like i don't know like all of a
sudden now uh
the other night like two nights in a row
back to back
i'm cruising at 80 bpms and i'm playing
it at 85
pretty comfortably and actually went up
to 90 the other
the songs at 95. i'm literally in
striking distance and at 90
i i could play the lick uh three times
in a row
like he does at the beginning of the
song um
and then just for the [ __ ] i better go
let me try to play along the song just
to see where i am with the rest of the
song
it was still a little bit too fast for
me but it didn't feel like
mind-blowingly fast so today i'm gonna
play
and i'm gonna start at 60 bpms get
myself up to 80 and then for 80. just
[ __ ] play the song for like five 10
minutes whatever 10 minutes a long time
but like five minutes
and just have fun and then bump it up to
82 83 and then ended 85
and just get it to the point where 85 is
as comfortable as 80. before i even
think about 86 forget about 90.
and um i just think the way
i'm scatterbrained add [ __ ] [ __ ]
i literally went through like you know
like uh the history of
what what my brain is like how they used
to describe it when i was a kid it was
you're a [ __ ]
and then it became a little you know
he's a little scatterbrained and then it
became
add they just keep whittling it down of
uh
you know we know the deal so i just have
to understand that i am a scatter brain
lunatic so um
i just try to uh
acknowledge that i try not to fight it
and i just try to just be aware that
this is what i do when this gets in my
way
so make an effort
to that when you are practic practicing
to be as focused as long as you can
and when that [ __ ] [ __ ] starts coming
up i want to do this i want to do this
just go play a couple of songs
and then come back to what you were
working on have like your scatter brain
[ __ ] while you're playing songs and
[ __ ] around but when you're working
on the thing you know be it for a minute
or [ __ ] 10 quality minutes just make
sure you're just hyper focused
on doing your thing so um i don't know
i'm beyond excited about that and now
i'm applying
what i'm learning with this thing to
everything else that i want to practice
but i have to also be
trying not to now also be oh this is
working good times bad times
let me try this with [ __ ] that that
that vinny paul thing and the alex van
halen thinking 50 000 other [ __ ]
things
um i don't want to do that either so uh
i got to make sure i just
work on this thing if i can get anything
out of covid
if i can learn this skill that will
bring at will put absolutely no
food on the [ __ ] table um
anyway let me see if i got the reads
here for the week for the week
so uh my prediction okay
because toronto and the blue jackets
have not played yet
i have no you know what
ah man i i'm all i'm gonna say is i'm
rooting
i'm rooting for toronto but i will tell
you
nobody can be dumb enough with what
they've done to their fan base to ever
put money on that [ __ ] team
um
it's almost like nobody wants to win
that [ __ ] series sorry i'm typing on
my [ __ ] password i'm trying to look
at my goddamn email here
and what do they do i'm just verifying
that it's you
oh yeah somebody trying to break into my
account to steal my junk mail
okay okay i don't want
okay protect your account confirm all
right beautiful i don't want to give you
my phone number
i love their idea that
i should give you my phone number like
this is some sort of safe [ __ ] thing
to do where you're obviously concerned
that somebody's breaking into my [ __ ]
account
by giving my phone number then you know
then what the [ __ ] am i supposed to do
all right here we go i got some i got
some reads here
um well here the reads
do i have any advertising oh jesus
christ
i swear to god i'm gonna have to start
walking the block
i got no stand-up gigs the [ __ ]
the goddamn i don't have any [ __ ]
advertising it's just well what
nobody's making any money and nobody can
buy anything oh there they go there they
are i got some reads they just came in
hot off the press smell the ink
i got one read one reed or another
i'm gonna read it and buy some
government cheese
um policy genius everybody
policy genius saves their home and auto
customers
an average of one hundred twenty seven
dollars a year
now that sounds like an honest number
right if they said eleven hundred bucks
you'd be like all right they might be
fudging it but no
this is how accurate they are at policy
genius one thousand
one hundred twenty dollars a year
by shopping top-rated insurers in one
place do you realize if you lived to be
1 127 years old you would have outlived
jim morrison by a thousand 100 years
if you think that's fascinating listen
to the rest of this if you're thinking 1
127 is a weirdly specific amount you're
right
but they crunch the numbers and that's
just what it is in fact
crunching numbers is one of the things
policy genius does best look at that
they were addressing how accurate that
number was
and i [ __ ] like a comedian i [ __ ]
i i tried to top their story before they
could even tell it my apologies
to everybody a policy genius um
it's a bit of an arrogant name okay i
can't tell you that all right
uh i don't call myself billy know it all
burr
i mean i think things like that i would
never say it because i have a need to be
liked all right their insurance
marketplace makes it easy
easy easy to uh to compare rates from
the top home and auto insurance
companies to find you the best price
here's how it works all you gotta do is
head to policygenius.com and answer a
few quick questions about yourself
and your proper tie after that policy
genius does all the work
put your feet up enjoy a cigar
they'll compare your existing policy
against the others in the market
to make sure you're getting the right
coverage at the best possible price if
policy genius finds a better rate
than what you're currently paying
they'll get you switched for free
that's kind that's that kind of service
has earned policy genes of five star
rating
across over 1600 reviews on trustpilot
in google i mean i don't know why you
wouldn't do this
especially now so if you're a homeowner
head to policygenius.com right now
to get started they saved their home and
auto insurance customers an average of
what
1 twenty seven dollars a year
all right who knows what weirdly
specific amount they could save you
and you'll never know unless you go to
policygenius.com
all right is there is there a way for
them to [ __ ] understand that i sent
him there
okay i don't get all david foster here
but i thought my name was supposed to be
in the copy
um i had a bad run in with wildlife
i got to talk to you about um i came out
to my garage
and i opened the door and there was a
little gecko sitting in there right
speaking of insurance right little
[ __ ] lizard whatever you call these
things
and i'm looking at this thing and it's
just [ __ ] laying there i'm like all
right i know the deal
it's sitting there right now going all
right if i taste
totally still maybe this giant thing
won't eat me
so i nonchalantly lay down a bunch of
things so this thing can't scurry
further into my garage
and um i made a lot of dumb moves in my
life but like
underestimating the scurrying ability of
a little lizard
is right at the top of the list because
i thought i had this [ __ ] boxed in
the second i reached down to grab it by
its tail and just sort of take it
outside
uh this [ __ ] just like
started scurrying right and i was going
you [ __ ] i was trying to catch
it and then i finally cornered the thing
and i was trying to be [ __ ] nice and
but it wouldn't let me
you know i was trying to ease it out the
door so i finally had to take off my
rubber flip-flop and i flipped him
out the door pretty fast and then he
just [ __ ] laid there
and i was like oh [ __ ] that i heard him
and one of his arms was kind of like
underneath his body and
uh so i went up and i touched him and he
barely moved
and then i was just like oh
oh this thing's dying that's why it came
in
to my garage i think because it just
wanted to die
because it wasn't from the flip because
i flipped them out before with my
[ __ ] flip-flop
and uh at least i hope it wasn't that
but he already wasn't
moving because i thought he was like
asleep cause i touched him and he didn't
[ __ ] move i think he's like trying to
die with dignity and i [ __ ] it up so
anyway
i did what i did in here i came out and
he was still lying there i'm like ah
[ __ ] now he's gonna lay here and get
eaten by a [ __ ] snake
you know i'm not supposed to interfere
with nature i kind of just did or
whatever so anyway so i went into the
house and i came back
and the [ __ ] was back inside my
garage again and
you know what i just said all right dude
you can die in here
i get it all right he's just looking at
me and i'm looking at him
and i'm like okay you win i don't want
uh
you know who wants to get [ __ ] eaten
alive
you know so there you go i'm sure i'll
get some [ __ ] from the [ __ ]
the lizard left
um anyway uh plowing ahead here
uh let's do some of the uh
some of the reads here um yeah i really
[ __ ] when it comes to animals i mean
other than like
a [ __ ] mosquito i can kill mosquitoes
but i got like real i got [ __ ] issues
and for half a second i i wouldn't be
able to kill a chicken
uh i heard that they could count to ten
but then all these chicken farmers are
like
uh they kill each other man that whole
pecking order they will peck a chicken
to death
i mean let me ask you a question would
you rather have a [ __ ] you know cause
all i'm gonna do is just come over
and chop its [ __ ] head off quickly
i'm not gonna would you rather be pecked
to death
or just have yourself stuck in a
guillotine and have the [ __ ] knife
come slamming down on you
you know um
i would choose the guillotine i'm not
saying i wouldn't be laying there like
ah what are you doing
don't do it i i would definitely beg it
for my life
but i would rather do that than somebody
just flicking me in the ear until i
[ __ ] died um
anyway i watched a lot of [ __ ] on
[ __ ] animals i was watching coyotes
i just can't stop watching this [ __ ] you
know
these life and death struggles that they
[ __ ] have out there
um i can't i was watching [ __ ]
coyotes uh
it's weird i can watch it kill a cat but
i can't i hate watching him kill dogs
uh i watched a leopard though a leopard
somehow got a domestic dog and had the
[ __ ] thing up the tree but didn't
know how to finish it off
and then somehow the dog got free and
[ __ ] ran away
um i'm like wasn't that thing like
biting into your neck i mean you [ __ ]
had a hell of a weekend there buddy
um but i don't understand people that
leave
their domesticated animals outside
at night i just don't understand i mean
even during the day i don't know where
you guys live but out here we got these
[ __ ]
we have hawks and [ __ ] out here and they
did i tell this story i was on crenshaw
boulevard one time
before the [ __ ] pandemic bumper to
bumper traffic
and uh all of a sudden the people in
front of me were like on
like was two lanes right and they were
both like opening
like going over the double line and the
other one was going more towards the
curb there was obviously something
laying in the road
and as i drove by i you know when i came
up to what it was there was a falcon
just standing on top of a pigeon waiting
for it to die and the pigeon was
flapping his [ __ ] wings and [ __ ]
and i was like but i had to keep going
you know la traffic and i want somebody
to shoot me right so i was just like
did i just see what i just saw and then
i just saw this [ __ ] pigeon
like fly right by the i think it was i
think the the uh
the hawk got freaked out by um
by the cars and [ __ ] and just sort of
let the [ __ ] thing go
um i can't imagine that man those
[ __ ] birds of prey i mean that's like
freddy krueger times two right those
talons coming at you
um i've watched all of those bird videos
um i watched this giant skinny [ __ ]
bird try to steal an
eagle's meal because the eagle was in a
cage
and he stuck his [ __ ] long skinny
head in through the bars and stole some
of his [ __ ]
food and the look and the goddamn well
the eagles always have the same
look on their face they never look happy
right
so it finishes uh
by the way why do birds of prey have
those angry eyes and why the [ __ ]
like uh the meaner the snake is the more
it has those mean eyes
and they've really used that other than
a lot of automotive design like with
fast cars and [ __ ] they try to have like
those [ __ ] venomous snake or
bird of prey eyes it's really weird
you know and then you look at [ __ ] that
gets eaten
right look at deers they're big brown
eyes
like hey man i'm just trying to chill
over here man um
but anyway uh sort of this [ __ ] bird
sticks its skinny goddamn head through
the bars
takes some of the [ __ ] eagles food
the eagles look at the thing like
i'd like to see you try that again and
the big [ __ ] dope does it again and
the bird
the [ __ ] eagle just grabs him by his
face just grabbed him by his beak
and held on to it and the [ __ ] the
the skinny bird's like all right all
right all right all right
[Music]
he [ __ ] let him go that was the end
of that
but it just struck me as funny where
that [ __ ] skinny ass
bird is like you would never [ __ ]
with an eagle then now it's behind bars
and i was trying to think if i went to
jail there was some guy in there that
could beat the [ __ ] out of me
i wouldn't try to steal his [ __ ] from
the [ __ ] cafeteria
commissary whatever the [ __ ] they say um
i wanted him to kill him i wanted him to
pull him in by his beak and then grab
him by his [ __ ] throat
i don't know i got to get back on the
road dude i'm literally i i it's so
[ __ ] funny because i
i quit porn i don't watch porn anymore i
haven't watched it in like [ __ ] three
months but
and then something has to fill the void
so now i'm just watching animals kill
each other
i mean i don't know
good thing i quit watching porn i think
i was on my way to snuff films oh
jesus bill all right let's do some reads
here for
the week what do we got here what do we
got here
dude uh i don't know how to say this
napoleon
napoleon not napoleon napoleon
n a p o e o n
um november alpha papa
oscar echo oscar november napoleon
uh hey billy big bollocks uh thought i'd
share a couple of napoleon facts oh this
is a this is a uh
i thought this was an advertising read
so it's supposed to say napoleon it just
says n-a-p-o-e-o-n
um all right that isn't on him i think i
i rushed the great andrew themillis this
week because i was recording so early i
cut him off guard so he sent me these
things over okay napoleon
hey billy big bullocks uh billy freckled
bollocks correction
thought i'd share a couple of napoleon
facts a little smiley face one did you
know that napoleon was the average
height for a european those days
no i didn't that's [ __ ] great to know
so he wasn't really short so it had
nothing to do with any of that
so evidently everybody else got taller
than over the years thought that he was
a shorter guy
seven wars were declared on napoleon not
so much
a warmonger yeah but you gotta think if
seven people declare war on you at some
point it's like what am i doing
right anyway a large chunk of current
slash
existing european laws were created
during napoleon's administration
four it was um
it was east it really was
east india company versus napoleon the
company had a standing army of 200 000
twice of the british army this is all
vague [ __ ] to it i don't know what any
of this is also it was in boston that
east india company t was dumped into the
sea that sparked another
conflict well it seems to me that you're
you're
french on some level or you like
napoleon
or you're a contrarian because everybody
said this little [ __ ] started a lot of
stuff let me see
napoleon
was average height he was five
six
yeah but george washington was 6-2
louis the 16th was 6-4 and adolf hitler
was 5-9
george washington was 6-2 get the [ __ ]
out of here
he was like a power forward back then
6-2 6-3 with the powdered wig
huh any fletch fans out there uh people
who ask all right
um was napoleon actually short
um in fact he was probably of average
height according to pre-metric system
french measures
he was a diminutive 5-2 but the french
inch
pounce of the time was 2.7
centimeters while the imperial inch was
2.54
oh so he was actually taller napoleon's
height revealed
but if napoleon was of average heist the
easy psychology doesn't work for him
yeah exactly they made it nice and
simple
he was a short [ __ ] right
who came up with that man that's like
that's like some ex-girlfriend [ __ ]
you know he's short he's got a little
dick that's why he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know
those basic you know
here to here to here you know this
then this equals that um that's actually
very interesting i don't know anything
about the east india company
what is the east india company let's
look that up east india
company east india company also known as
the honorable east india
the heic
um what did they do
uh it was formed does it still exist
yes it does founded in 1600 oh defunct
1874. my fault i read that wrong
wow what a run huh 274 years
crushing it what ended it
is that when the british took over their
[ __ ]
country is that what happened english
education act
now jesus i don't know i don't know
england's like the the original andy
cohens of the world you know
you know that guy gets all those real
housewives all stirred up it's like
england did that
before andy cohen except they did it
with countries and races of people
all andy cohen's doing is just getting a
couple of [ __ ] housewives to you know
he gets their blood up a little bit
that's my favorite [ __ ] thing to
watch now
karen when i can't say karen anymore
because that actually means something
now susan
when uh when
lacey called you a [ __ ] in episode two
you seem to really not like that like
you can call me a [ __ ] you can call me
a [ __ ]
i don't care i heard all those words
growing up but when you girls i mean you
cut
and he just sits there going go ahead go
ahead take up more time beautiful
beautiful
let's get it go i mean can you imagine i
mean
i think andy cohen could bring boxing
back the way that guy knows how to
[ __ ]
you know stir [ __ ] up out there i'm
telling you the man
has skills i'm a fan all right um ahead
well i have to look that up
i love the fact i'm gonna just start
saying that even though i don't even
know if it's a fact
he has a napoleon complex actually
napoleon they've now found out was
average height so you need a new
reference
just to [ __ ] piss somebody off
i mean that's really that's
probably 80 percent of my joy in the
world i can't say that because i got
kids now but you know what i mean
the me outside of my family 80 of my joy
comes from moments like that just being
a [ __ ] douche i i don't know why all
right canceling landlords
dear bill my girlfriend recently got
active
in politics uh occasionally she
says stuff that makes no sense because
it's secondhand information from memes
well yeah if that's what you're using
for your fountain of information
uh but who am i to judge i just google
[ __ ] and i read the first article like
most people
uh once i had to explain to her how
congress
worked because she insisted bills don't
go to capitol hill
oh boy i even sang her the song she
admitted to being wrong well that's a
big thing for an adult to do
and we agreed that for argument's sake
we
princey xi won't quote shitty internet
facts oh man this this
this relationship somebody's gonna have
to give here
either you're gonna have to give into
her tinfoil [ __ ] hat
reactionary [ __ ] like i said google
it
read the first article research done or
she's gonna have to come your way um and
it's gonna be torture for both of you
um all right cut to this week she's
saying that we need to cancel
landlords i had to try and gather myself
to explain to her that her father
was a landlord
he has a business and owns the building
but rents out
office space on the other side
she said quote that's different oh boy
she started spouting off all these
[ __ ] facts that i traced back to
a teen vogue article oh wow dude you are
a [ __ ]
so you write this [ __ ] down and then
look it up and oh i
god bless you sir you have both of your
balls
firmly within your grasp in this
relationship that you're going to
[ __ ] take her to
you're going to take her down to the mat
like this all right i'm 26 and she's 24.
i just don't understand
how you can rationalize that renting
out residential or commercial space is
like slavery
also aren't cities with stupidly high
rent prices
mostly blue um
well let's go through them certainly
everything out here in la is
uh la's a weird city man
it's it's red and blue people don't
realize that because all they do is pay
attention to hollywood but it gets
deep red pretty [ __ ] quick and it
gets deep blue pretty [ __ ] quick
obviously if you're near the hollywood
sign and
i don't i don't even know about that um
it's just that anybody who is red in
hollywood knows enough to keep their
[ __ ] mouth shut
uh anyways we don't live together so i'm
probably gonna break up with her in a
few weeks
um yeah you're definitely going to i'm
gonna send her a meme
about canceling girlfriends
because for me that's an important cause
go [ __ ] yourself love you bill
you know what i loved about this guy is
he had a problem
he faced it he realized there was no
solution
and now he's going to address it this
man is going to be
successful in life this is what it is
he saw a problem he tried to bring the
horse to water
the horse would not drink he sent it to
the glue factory and he's moving on
that's how you do it he didn't adopt it
he [ __ ] put it down
i love it i love that whole story
provided you know that was just your
side of the story
uh yeah why would you cancel landlords
you know what i mean you guys are
reminding me the people that wanted to
legalize weed
remember that we legalize weed man it's
a source for paper
you can make jackets and you can make
solar panels out of it man
now it's legal what are they doing
they're just trying to figure out ways
to get you more
[ __ ] up here's a way to be high but
you can actually hold a baby
with this strand this strand right here
you're just gonna stare at the wall for
[ __ ] three days it's like where's the
paper
huh where are my green hemp
[ __ ] crocs they know where to be
found people just want to get
[ __ ] up and not had not you know get
high and not have anybody give him any
[ __ ]
which i don't have a problem with i
really don't have a [ __ ] problem with
that so
um you know what is amazing to me is is
people that take those [ __ ] trips
the the the hallucinating ones and um
that just that's the thing that just
blows my [ __ ] mind people take that
and it's just like
and when you come back it's looks like
you're gonna realize that this reality
is just this reality that you [ __ ]
you know it's that we've just agreed
upon but you're going to be looking at
the world in a whole new [ __ ] way
it's like dude i can't even [ __ ] i
can't even handle reality
like i've always been like fascinated
with psychedelics but also
[ __ ] terrified just the whole thing
like
you need to take this but you got to
make sure you're in a safe place
um
i recently had a buddy of mine i this is
his story and he's a comedian so i can't
tell it but he had such a [ __ ]
hilarious
reaction to this thing that was speaking
to him
while he was high or tripping
and i tried to criticize him and his but
his reaction was like well who the [ __ ]
are you
you know which is just such the classic
stand-up comedian like mindset like what
this guy's great why
[Laughter]
not saying we're right but that's just
where the why the [ __ ] am i listening to
this guy
all right a woman my height all right
is this a woman colon my height
or a woman my height all right dear mr
burr
saw you at the bonscott gig at the start
of the pandemic that's the last gig i
did that's the last time i did
stand-up uh
and really understood how a world-class
comic uh
does it thanks for the laughs yeah i had
i had fun thank god i had a good set
anyway he goes i'm a 63 235 pound man oh
there you go play off stanley cup size
right there
that man will keep things settled down
on the ice there
and have dated or hooked up with women
with heights ranging from five three to
five
nine i've also hooked up with one woman
with two one or two women who were five
eleven i've recently met an
incredible seeming incredible seeming
woman
on a dating app we've spoken over the
phone
uh message a lot and are getting along
wonderfully okay where could this go
wrong
we're being hesitant on hanging out
because of the pandemic
but might do a sort of social distance
date if we both test negative
you know my my wife my smoking hot wife
was actually saying the other day she
said is the covid test the new aids test
because back in the day when we were
coming out that was a big thing have you
been tested
um all right judging by her photos and
her social media accounts
she's plenty beautiful the only thing is
she's sick
too i'm open to trying something
different
and even excited by the idea yeah what
the [ __ ] would want a giant woman
[Laughter]
that'd be [ __ ] great i wouldn't have
a problem with that
um but i'm worried that i might do or
say something
that is rude to her unique life
experience
i'm also a bit nervous because
all of my cool guy moves and swagger
have been in some way shaped by the fact
that i typically tower over girls sir
this
is great this is a great thing she's
gonna get you outside your comfort zone
before all you women start [ __ ]
chirping
like you don't have a type either okay
like you don't have your little safety
[ __ ] zone
um i think it'd be funny if she's not
wearing heels you could call her shorty
but just something she probably never
had she's going to be so psyched that
you're 6'3
you know what i mean that she finally is
gonna be uh
you know i don't know she guys are
roughly the same
but can you imagine her back in the day
dating like a guy five foot six and she
wants to be held and feel
safe you know what i mean and he's
hanging on to her like a [ __ ] one of
those creepy toddlers that breastfeeds
too long
[Laughter]
by the way i gotta look that up i don't
give a [ __ ] at this point
um that's gonna be my excuse when the
feds come in
uh we'd like to talk to you about your
search engine do a podcast with no
guests the [ __ ] am i supposed to do here
at what age is it
creepy to still
breastfeed oh man they got to do this on
uh
steve harvey's show there the family
feud
the mayo clinic website states that
children are weaned off
on an average between ages two and four
what the [ __ ] you listen nobody
remembers
what happens to them when they're three
you can't remember you
do not need to remember
hanging on your mom's boob you don't
want to do that and in some culture
extended breastfeeding continues
for a couple of years past that while
the american academy of family
physicians recommends breastfeeding past
infancy and gradually weaning off at no
precise age
all right here's a great article
breastfeeding a three and a half year
old
isn't creepy it's hilarious uh
i was on the couch feeding my newborn
second child when her older sibling
snuggled up close and asked mama can i
have
some too she's almost
forced uh
i don't want to read this ah
oh my god gross i'm just reading the
dialogue
she can't say milk she can only say mao
can i have some mao and she goes maui's
for babies
the kid said please just a teeny sip she
said no
hey no means no you little [ __ ] get away
from her tits
she burst into tears dismayed we were
back here again after a long
arduous weaning process she didn't
self-wean as i expected in around
a year uh 15 months 18 months or two i
thought
oh she didn't wean as i expected around
a year 15 months 18 months or two
i thought of my own mother's claim that
i self-weaned at eight months in our
conversations surrounding
my extended breastfeeding
going to let her breastfeed till she
goes to car college she chided
i said her frozen baggies
of milk are in a care pack i don't want
to read this
i don't want to read this you know what
i don't feel comfortable reading this i
i apologize for looking that up and
putting that [ __ ] in your [ __ ]
oh my god all right
anyways yeah she's gonna get you outside
your comfort zone
uh all right this is a strange new world
for me to be frank
um i did some research on my particular
situation to no avail
i did however read that sex and
basically everyday
interactions are better with the partner
close closer to one's height
any thoughts opinions insights or advice
would be great
yeah you know what i say buddy dive in
dive in and have fun
she seems wonderful you know
the fact that you guys you know meeting
someone during a pandemic you actually
have to take the time to kind of get to
know him a little bit right so you don't
rush into anything
um and you don't hang around for the
convenience
of someone to so you're not lonely or
the sex or whatever so i think this is a
good thing i think you should definitely
do it
and um you know that'd be [ __ ]
hilarious though if she
i don't want to get involved in it
because you might fall in love with this
girl but there's certain positions that
you'll then have to [ __ ] figure out
because she's
you know not super short you know much
shorter than you you know what i mean
maybe you'll have to stand on something
if she's in a certain position wearing
high heels
[ __ ] like six seven you know what's
great though is no one's gonna [ __ ] with
your kids all right best wishes to you
and your growing family go [ __ ] yourself
all right
good luck sir all right boyfriend hates
my armpit hair well yeah
all right hi bill would you like it if
he started to have tits i mean that's
just
how it is in the west you're not
supposed to have all that having armpit
hair was something that is just
it's it's not mainstream you're going a
little punk rock here
i remember when they did the german
version of 99 luff balloons and when she
put her hands where but the
paper dude she put her [ __ ] arms up
we all went
all right hi bill love your podcast my
boyfriend and i listen to it together
and i'm sure
he'll be thrilled if this makes it on
uh despite the topic he doesn't like
that i don't shave my armpit hair
constantly and constantly comments on it
to clear a couple things up
i'm not doing it because i identify as a
hippie or i'm taking a counterculture
stance
i just never like shaving in general
oh see like a bum at least if you were
[ __ ] attached to some
ideology i would get it how come guys
don't have to do it but we have to i get
that
you just some how would you like if you
just sat around [ __ ] all unshaven
looking like [ __ ] pluto on
on popeye listen this is what i think
all right
i think if like you know the person
you're banging
is turned off by something you should
make a [ __ ] effort
all right obviously if they go your tits
too small you know you tell them to [ __ ]
themselves okay you need a nose job
tell them to go [ __ ] themselves but like
you know if if i was doing something or
you know whatever the [ __ ] i was doing
the person i was with saying hey that
kind of turns me off i'd be like i got
it i got it
shaving my armpit hair whatever the [ __ ]
i got to do
anyway he says it's weird and he notices
it
often when i wear a sleeveless shirt and
we're around people
yeah yeah you're wearing a sleeveless
shirt you're being a douche
you know he doesn't like it and then
you're flaunting it you're [ __ ] a man
yeah you're like [ __ ] making him look
like a jerk
i don't see why it matters most guys
have hair there why can't i
you passive aggressive little so-and-so
there's your ideology right there just
come out and say it
i have good hygiene i don't smell
well listen first of all you're you're
applying
you're saying all of this all right
good hygiene and you don't smell that's
not you don't make that decision the
people around you tell you that
how the [ __ ] would you know if you don't
smell you're in the eye of the [ __ ]
hurricane
anyways and it doesn't affect anyone
other than their supposedly
emotional recreations
uh reaction sorry doesn't affect anyone
other than their supposedly emotional
reactions to body hair
to me it seems to bother him because it
goes against what he saw
growing up since most women in the us
chose to shave
listen you are 100
doing the feminist thing here most guys
have hair there why can't i
and you're just reacting this way
because western society has told you
this
so don't say that you're not you you're
you're doing this for feminist [ __ ]
reasons i'm not saying you're a hardcore
feminist i'm not saying you're douche
i'm not saying you're wrong but you are
doing this for a [ __ ] reason
um my question is
is why do most men find this to be weird
or even repulsive
thanks for reading if you read it that's
it go [ __ ] yourself i would say the same
reason why most women find
man tits repulsive it's like why can't i
have tits you have tits
there's just certain things that are
um
you know this is this is what i'll try
to do this as nicely as possible
the error in progressive thought is
they they had this thing as like what is
normal there is no normal it's like yeah
there is there is a normal
and all of these super progressive
people also have a normal or else
you would walk around and you would
never be uncomfortable
if i walk down this my driveway and i
see a [ __ ]
bear in my driveway
that's not normal but i could argue it
is normal
i'm outside bears live outside i'm not
used to seeing a bear
in my [ __ ] driveway now
if i get uncomfortable does that mean i
[ __ ] hate bears
sweetheart you got a [ __ ] goddamn den
of bears under your [ __ ] armpit see
you're freaking them out
listen it's it's all how you grew up
okay if you grew up and women had hair
under their arms no it wouldn't bug you
but
but we didn't so it becomes weird
there's societies and like there's like
things where guys walk down the street
holding their hands we don't do that
here
i could never do that to my with my
another one of my guy friends i i didn't
know what the
i don't know what would happen to our
friendship we can never talk to each
other again
all right but here's the deal as much as
you're probably judging me now if it was
reversed
and it was another country of doing it
progressive people be like well you have
to respect their culture
um so here's the thing you can have hair
under your [ __ ] arms you have
every right to have hair on your arms
and he has every right to be [ __ ]
grossed out by it
and i think he's being a great [ __ ]
guy tolerating it
yes tolerating it he's putting up with
this thing and that's what you do in a
relationship
you tolerate if you really like somebody
is you put up with their [ __ ] and
your [ __ ]
is you know you got [ __ ] you got
kevin mchale's [ __ ] arm
armpit hair um i don't there is nothing
wrong
for a guy to be repulsed by arm by
armpit hair
any more than uh if a woman is repulsed
by something that a guy does you can't
help how you're [ __ ]
wired and this whole [ __ ] thing you
know they've been doing this thing where
like
well what is beauty what is you know
it's
like i if madison avenue has been the
the people telling us what beauty is
shut the [ __ ] up you know you know what
a good-looking person looks like
and you know what a [ __ ] [ __ ] up
looking person looks like
okay because that whole [ __ ] [ __ ]
that that
feminists argue about beauty notice they
don't really argue it for men
they only argue with for women okay they
want to eat cookies and [ __ ] be on
billboards that's what they want to do
they they want they want they want to be
just in the [ __ ] express lane
their whole life and [ __ ] not have to
do anything
um and then meanwhile we have to
continue to do all of our [ __ ] you know
what i mean i mean
did you ever see like uh i don't know is
there any sort of male movement out
there to be like going like what is with
all of these
[ __ ] things on tv about you know
what's wrong with an
older man not being able to get his dick
hard anymore i mean everything on there
is you got to have abs your dick's got
to be [ __ ] saluting the flag and you
got to have a [ __ ] lion's mane of
hair every [ __ ] thing
on there has it who gives a [ __ ] it is
what it is so here's the deal
your boyfriend hates your armpit hair um
you know i got to be honest with you if
if my wife had a problem with something
that i could correct physically
without any sort of major surgery i
would do it for her
i wouldn't have a [ __ ] problem with
it i mean
i don't think it's that big of a [ __ ]
deal i don't even think you have to be a
jerk about it
i don't think you have to shave your
[ __ ] armpits you don't have to be but
two things you need to do you need to
own up to the fact that you're doing it
for a [ __ ] reason
um if you're honest with him that then
he could have an honest conversation
with you because you're trying to act
like
i'm just you know i'm not being like a
hippie or a counter culture person
you you you are which is totally fine
um i'll be honest with you i it's
i will say this it's not as gross to me
as it used to be
it's a little more uh
mainstream i would say but like uh i'll
tell you something that i never [ __ ]
the completely shaved
[ __ ] beaver it's just like i'm trying
to be a little woman
here
that that that that that that that that
is always [ __ ] creeped me out
just creeps me out all right um
[ __ ] creeps me up so i i
you know i don't know and i did i ever
say i don't think i ever said anything
uh i i passively aggressive what do you
think it'd be like yeah it's pretty
intense
so like yeah i mean i you know
i like being in the crowd i don't need
to be that far backstage
[Laughter]
all right underrated small town story
uh hey billy crimson crotch i like that
one
i'm roll tide uh have you seen the new
documentary movie
tread yet on netflix it's awesome it's
about an old school welder
that lives in a small town in colorado
called uh
granby in the 1990s and early 2000s
he opened a welding shop in town and
pretty much welded everything for
everybody anyway shh this i'm definitely
gonna watch this because i'm
fascinated with welding uh he caught up
in
he got caught up in some drama with the
old boys club
of small town politics and his neighbor
and town board
turned against him stating and started
[ __ ] with his shop and way of life
i don't know you're going to ruin it
here i'm not going to read anything else
i'm going to read this [ __ ]
uh tread t-r-e-a-d on netflix i believe
i will be watching that tonight
i mean how do you not watch a
documentary on welding
how do you not well easily you get
involved in all these playoffs well
guess what i have time for i have time
right now to watch the end
of the st louis blues uh game and then
i'm gonna watch the [ __ ] um
i'm gonna watch the uh what are the
toronto maple leafs
i have to root for them but i also love
the columbus blue jackets i
i really like both of those teams but
you know toronto has been waiting
forever so
uh i don't know we shall see what
happens anyways
anyway that is the uh the podcast
everybody
uh you and your armpit hair or your lack
of armpit hair
have a great [ __ ] time what a [ __ ]
i i i hate passive aggressive [ __ ]
okay what i'm not doing it because of
this and then you say why you're doing
it
and then you're wearing tank tops out in
front of his friends
okay you know what you're doing you're
putting your statement out there
and then you're trying to get well what
if i didn't what if i don't shave my
armpits would you have a problem with
that
you're just starting [ __ ] you know what
you're doing all right you're just not
as good at it as you think you are
um i haven't said that um
you know i would not kick any woman out
of bed that i don't pit here i would not
do that
if they were [ __ ] nice enough to want
to [ __ ] me there i said it okay there
you go
god bless everybody go [ __ ] yourselves
and i'll check in on you on thursday